cette unité admiratrice qui va te poser
une question c est à vous de parler la
petite z
c'est cela oui c'est cela oui c'est un
agressé plein de questions tabac fera
savoir si telle sur la dame du
feuilleton miss nagui ou alors j'ai pas
de piston pour la tv parce que pour
passer à la télé c'est sûr notamment
traite entités et comme elle se voit si
t'es un gros bazar percussions et que du
personnel pour faire le jeu face à ce
qu'il a dit il faut prendre la rubrique
faits divers alors été c'est d'aller
chez emmaüs avec les vêtements pour noël
comme chef peut-on répondre jamais ça il
est fort quand même depuis tout à
l'heure tu as pendant ces clous de tête
de se calmer j'ai risqué ma caisse qui
fait mieux les filles que les hommes en
forme